I've been in recent set of videos that
we've done related to HTML really I've
taken a severe beating in the latest one
that I'm a disgrace to full professors
that I don't know what programming
language is and how it differs from the
market language and my attitude is going
to be well I stand by what I say hTML is
a very restricted form of programming
language in my view so we need to
justify that and I need to say the
outside that you don't need to see all
the previous HTML videos in order to
understand this one because it really
comes down to something that's actually
very fundamental in the end it comes
down to two different styles of
programming language that are
interrelated that you can differentiate
in a way between them and when does one
merge into another and these two ways of
doing programming are known in the trade
generically as either the imperative
style or declarative now the one that
most of you will be the more familiar
with is the imperative so we'll do that
first this is really just programming as
you and I understand it you take your
language of your choice assembler Java C
basic whatever and you are required to
give a detailed specification of how you
are going to do this problem and as we
know this detailed specification might
be simple arithmetic programming
statements it might require going round
things in loops it would certainly
require taking decisions so it will have
if statements inside it so if you like
ordinary straightforward detailed
nuts-and-bolts programming is in an
imperative style because you say have to
say how you are going to solve the
problem I'll put how in quotes here
saying that leads you to if for
arithmetic statements whatever you need
so this is setting out how you going to
do something if this button is pressed
then do this yes
yes and the vast majority of programs
that most people think of in terms of
programming are done in this style
now what about declarative then well
declarative it's a more functional style
of programming where the interpreter for
your language does the details and
actually one style can merge into
another and I've got a very good example
of my own and we've done it on computer
files I wrote a program to do the
Ackermann function I think it's my
biggest hit so far that particular video
and within the function a common we saw
program statements we saw use of
recursion we saw a command calling
Ackerman and all this kind of stuff and
finally returning and delivering back an
answer however back in the main program
where I call up Ackerman with certain
organize and I call up the Ackermann
function as the arguments people I don't
worry about the implementation details
of Ackerman I just call it up at the end
of a big printf statement as I recall I
say declaratively give me a comment do
it for me I've forgotten the details of
how I did it and if you know this the
whole idea of writing your own library
full of functions for a particular job
is that you can then work more
abstractly and as a higher level you can
say I wrote those 20 years I've gone how
I did them but it doesn't matter
dumi akima with parameters thing and
things like that so you see the one can
merge into the other as you take a more
functional approach you could argue
loose leave every time you use a library
of functions that you bought in from
somewhere then you are becoming more
declarative in the way that you use it
so the point about declarative is you
don't have to go into the nuts and bolts
details you just ask for what you want
and magically it happens typical
examples of real declarative languages
and are things like Haskell what are the
trade-offs about this well you could
probably say that most of these
declarative languages don't work on the
they're metal like you see program could
do eventually they are interpreted with
a layer of software between you and the
bare metal now that gives you
flexibility because the Haskell
interpreter can be basically ported to
all sorts of architectures something's
going to do that hard work but then you
know that if you take the Haskell
program along you can just run it you
don't have to convert it into a binary
it just runs on the interpretive mode so
it's trade-offs and other things being
equal it's less true now it used to be
you lose a little bit of efficiency in
an interpreter whereas you know if you
refine a thing right down to a hardcore
binary it'll go off like a mother RT we
hope and some languages as we know have
a compromise here Java started life as
being a portable interpreted system but
with a syntax it was really pretty much
like see but it's notable now when
you've developed from the Java there's
very often an option to say if you want
to compile this and make a real
executable binary yes you can do that
but during development you get a lot of
flexibility
I just been able to do things and try
them out instantly that then I hope has
given you a bit more insight into what
the imperative versus the declarative
approach is and that's very relevant to
discussions of whether hTML is or is not
a programming language we all know
pointy brackets h1 means give me a
heading level one now of course I have
to show where the stuff that is your
heading the text ends but to me you can
say look I'm calling up the function h1
I'm giving it the argument this is my
heading to be done in h1 style an end of
h1 is really just to say oh by the way
there's no other way I can signify where
my text string ends it's
semicolon anything like that
conventionally its end of h1 so to me
yes you could think of that as being a
function call in a way however some of
you really did hit home a bit more
accurately I think when you said it
can't be a programming language really
because it's not chewing complete now
that is a topic I'm sorry I hate doing
cliffhanger as you know I do that's a
topic that we have mentioned time to
time but it's big enough that we need to
do a separate video really on that it's
perfectly correct that HTML could never
be thought of as a full-blown
programming language it can't do if
statements in its raw vanilla form
there's no way inside HTML that you can
say give me a megabyte more space to
work with is just not part of the
language
somebody has pointed out I think that
HTML with CSS it does become a very
powerful Turing complete language but
you wouldn't want to use it it's not
general-purpose that's another thing it
really is a question of is it imperative
is it declarative this is declarative
but is it general-purpose no this is
really for programming webpages that's
the way I think of it and also like I
say it's not Turing complete but you can
certainly argue that anything that takes
tags as if they were function calls and
interpreter and does them for you is in
some restricted sense in my view anyway
a programming language if you're
like first two traps which we've got
here offer when M gets down to zero and
when n gets down at zero then in the end
it will terminate